if they care at all about their children
or grandchildren now sometimes I doubt
that I think you know grandchildren now
don't write a thank-you for the
Christmas presents they're walking on
their pants or their cap on backwards
listen to em I'm a man the Snoopy Snoopy
poop dog and they don't like them if
they care at all about their children or
grandchildren now sometimes I doubt that
walking on the pants or the cap on
backwards wish my enema man with Snoopy
Snoopy poop dog walking on their pants
or the cap on back wish they enema man
this movie Snoopy school star don't
write it thank you for the Christmas
presents they're rich they enema man the
Snoopy Snoopy boot dog walking on their
pants or the cap on back for children or
grandchildren I don't like just
functional children but I don't like
them pubic hair in the coat I don't like
them talking back to your mother
I don't like movie long dong silver and
I like that kind of a man nope you
smoked the enema man nope there's no
feeling oh man no fish no fish mythical
dark and this one ain't going away this
is a stink bomb in the garden party I
was very embarrassing